ihre kolleginnen herzlich willkommen in
der bundespressekonferenz an diesem
freitag wie so oft an freitagen in den
vergangenen monaten zu einer
pressekonferenz zur unterlage mit
gesundheitsminister jens spahn dem
präsidenten des robert koch instituts
jutta binner und dem leiter der
forschungsgruppe für infektions
immunologie und impfstoffforschung der
berliner charité leif erik sander
herzlich willkommen ihn von allen dreien
werden wir eingangs etwas hören bevor
wir zu ihren fragen kommen
und bevor wir richtig loslegen gestatten
sie mir noch ein paar worte dazu wo wir
hier sind und wer wir hier sind der die
bundespressekonferenz ist ein verein von
journalistinnen und journalisten die
über bundespolitik berichten
wir sind regierungsunabhängig
organisiert und veranstalten hier
pressekonferenzen bei denen mitglieder
der bundespressekonferenz und des
verbands der auslandspresse gelegenheit
haben unseren gästen fragen zu stellen
wir werden in der korona pandemie vom
fernsehsender phoenix begleitet und
unterstützt mit einer
gebärdendolmetscherin für diebe herzlich
danken und dann gegen die los herr
sparen sie haben das wort liebe frau
busch und meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren heute endet die letzte
sitzungswoche des deutschen bundestages
vor der sommerpause und ich möchte
diesen anlass nutzen um mich bei den
parlamentariern den abgeordneten aller
fraktionen zu bedanken für manche
kritische aber vor allem meist auch sehr
konstruktive diskussionen und vor allem
auch für die gute zusammenarbeit die
krise hat auch dem parlamentarismus
einiges abverlangt diese zeit der krise
war und ist eine zumutung für die
freiheitliche demokratie
aber wir haben auch gezeigt dass das
zusammenspiel aus parlament aus
regierung aus bund und bundesländern
auch in schweren zeiten funktioniert und
wir haben uns vor allem auch unter
stress auch unter schweren bedingungen
vertrauen und aufeinander verlassen
können
und bei aller notwendigen kritik im
vergleich mit vielen anderen ländern in
europa und auf der welt sind wir bis
hierhin alles in allem vergleichsweise
gut durch diese pandemie durch diese
jahrhundertkrise gekommen vorneweg der
bundesrat wird heute noch zwei wichtige
entscheidungen in der gesundheitspolitik
treffen die direkt oder auch mittelbar
mit der pandemie zu tun haben
zum ersten wird der pflege schutzschirm
um drei monate verlängert werden damit
wird der mehraufwand und die
mindereinnahmen von pflegeheimen von
pflegeeinrichtungen ambulant und
stationär ausgeglichen in dieser
pandemie die pandemie bedingten
betriebswirtschaftlichen schwierigkeit
in dem wir viele einrichtungen entstehen
wir geben damit der pflege sicherheit in
auch dieser phase der pandemie
zudem beraten die länder heute im
bundesrat auch unsere pflegereform damit
stellen wir sicher dass pflegekräfte in
der altenpflege künftig nach tarif
bezahlt werden pflegekräfte das hat
diese pandemie uns einmal mehr vor augen
geführt pflegekräfte sind der kitt
dieser alternden gesellschaft die sind
für viele menschen für jede familie im
alltag eine wichtige unterstützung mit
ihrer expertise mit ihrem engagement mit
ihrem können und deswegen geht es uns
darum bessere arbeitsbedingungen zu
ermöglichen damit haben wir übrigens
schon vor der pandemie begonnenen
erkranken wie in der altenpflege aber
ich bin sehr froh darüber dass mit der
entscheidung heute des bundesrates wir
tatsächlich gerade für die altenpflege
haben noch einen unterschied machen
können sehr sehr konkret was bessere
bezahlung mehr kolleginnen und kollegen
und auch mehr verantwortung angehen
in der kroner lage heute beschäftigt uns
vor allem auch die delta variante viele
treibt die frage um ob wir auf eine
mögliche vierte welle mit dieser
variante zu steuern
ob der sommerurlaub möglich ist wie
geplant ob uns wieder ein schwieriger
herbst und winter bevorsteht
die einfache antwort auf diese frage ist
es liegt an uns wir dürfen
zuversichtlich in diesem sommer gehen
wir können im sommer genießen aber eben
mit vorsicht zu einem zu sorglosen
sommer darf kein sorgen
herbst werden und deswegen geht es wenn
ich von vorsicht rede um am ende zwei
drei ganz wichtige dinge das eine ist
vor allem dass wir weiterhin einen
unterschied machen zwischen draußen und
drinnen draußen geht ziemlich viel und
das wetter macht ja auch ziemlich viel
möglich draußen aber sehr wichtig ist
vor allem in innenräumen insbesondere
wenn viele menschen in einem raum sind
vor allem auch wenn nicht geimpfte und
nicht aktuell getestete dabei sind das
schutzmasken getragen werden und einfach
vor allem je nach größe des raumes wenn
es nicht so leicht ist wie hier dann
eben auch gelüftet wird die regeln die
wir eigentlich alle kennen jetzt auch
durch den sommer durch zu tragen es geht
um das reisen reisen ist möglich vor
allem auch innerhalb der europäischen
union in fast alle teile der eu gut
möglich weil die instanzen insgesamt
niedrig sind dadurch kann nur alle
bitten und der mund an die testangebote
auch zu nutzen die weiterhin kostenlos
jedem zur verfügung stehen wer will dass
die schulferien die schule nach den
ferien sorgenfreier starten können der
sollte sich und seine familie nach der
rückkehr aus dem urlaub einfach ein-
zwei- dreimal in einigen tagen abstand
testen wie es eben auch kostenlos
möglich ist und vor allem das impfen
hilft uns auch bei dieser variante stand
jetzt sind 70,5 millionen impfungen in
deutschland cupid 19 impfung gegeben
worden 44 millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger haben eine erste impfung erhalten
das in 52,9 prozent 28,3 millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger haben den vollen
impfschutz das in 34,1 prozent also mehr
als jeder zweite es mindestens einmal
geimpft mehr als jeder dritte hat den
vollen impfschutz zum grab mit blick auf
die delta variante ist wichtig die
zweite impfung auch wahrzunehmen
ich kann nur dafür werben die erste
impfung ist wichtig für einen ersten
schutz
aber gerade die data variante zeigt uns
die zweite impfung im vorgesehenen
zeitintervall ist auch sehr wichtig um
auch mit blick auf diese variante gut
geschützt zu sein
nochmal zur einordnung 63 prozent aller
app
sie haben eine erste impfung erhalten
ich habe letzte woche gesagt und ich
wiederhole es noch mal wir haben genug
impfstoff in der erwartung in den
nächsten wochen um allen impfwilligen
erwachsenen bis ende juli ein angebot
für eine erste impfung machen zu können
und wir können auch allen zwölf ist 18
jährigen bis ende august ermöglichen
eine erste impfung zu erhalten stand
heute haben 300.000 zwölf- bis
18-jährige eine erste impfung erhalten
das ist eine individuelle entscheidung
von kindern eltern und dem impfen den
arzt aber möglicherweise beeinflusst die
aktuelle delta entwicklung ja auch diese
individuelle entscheidung in der
abwägung
impfen ist das beste mittel gegen diese
pandemie impfung hilft auch gegen alle
bisher bekannten varianten
deswegen lautet heute mein appell einmal
mehr schritte nutzen sie die chance
lassen sie sich impfen
nahezu alle bundesländer stellen gerade
in diesen tagen wieder neue erst
impftermine auch in den impfzentren zur
verfügung in arztpraxen bei den
betriebsärzten ist es möglich sich
impfen zu lassen sich impfen zu lassen
im eigenen interesse um sich selbst zu
schützen aber es dient auch dem
gemeinwohl es ist im interesse von uns
allen wenn sich möglichst viele für eine
impfung entscheiden
denn wer nicht geimpft ist wird sich
unweigerlich früher oder später
infizieren impfung oder infektionen
das ist die wahl für jeden einzelnen und
das ist die wahl auch für uns als
gesellschaft die delta variante wird
über den sommer auch bei uns die
oberhand gewinnen das ist eher eine
frage von wochen als von monaten das
sehen wir ja auch in den aktuellen
zahlen die frage ist allerdings unter
welchen bedingungen bei wie vielen
geimpften und auch bei welcher inzidenz
denn natürlich steigt der prozentuale
anteil 15 prozent und der wird
mittlerweile wahrscheinlich auch da noch
mal deutlich gestiegen sein wir haben ja
wegen der genomsequenzierung die eine
zeit braucht immer einen leichten
zeitverzug aber das eine ist der
prozentuale anteil das andere ist die
absolute zahl und 15 oder 25 prozent von
500 infektionen am tag ist halt was
anderes als 15 oder 25 prozent von 5000
oder mehr infektionen am tag und
deswegen wir haben es in der hand auch
ob diese delta variante sich ausbreitet
mit einer zahl von vielen geimpften und
idealerweise bei geringen
infektionszahlen die ausgangslage ist
insgesamt also gut lassen sie uns dafür
sorgen dass das so bleibt beides gehört
dabei zusammen gut gelaunt in den sommer
aber eben auch geimpft in den sommer mit
begründeter zuversicht und mit der
notwendigen vorsicht sie das wort ja
wird morgen meine damen und herren die
fallzahlen
wir gehen weiter zurück und heute ist
die bundesweite 7 tages incidents sogar
bei 6,2 das ist eine wirklich sehr gute
erfreuliche entwicklungen auch die
todeszahlen die ans robert koch institut
übermittelt werden gehen zurück noch mal
einen ganz herzlichen dank für alle von
uns die zu diesem erfolg beigetragen
haben durch ein verantwortungsbewusstes
handeln so auf der anderen seite das
wurde schon angesprochene mti delta
variante zu wir haben in deutschland
inzwischen sehr viele proben sequenziert
inzwischen ist es so dass mehr als eine
von zehn proben sequenziert wird und
deshalb haben wir in sehr guten
überblick und die gelte variante nimmt
darunter zu die aktuellsten daten die
haben wir vorgestern auf unserer website
publiziert die stammen aus der zweiten
juliwoche weil es immer einen gewissen
zeitverzug gibt bei den sequenzierungen
und da lag der anteil schon bei 15
prozent
aber wir gehen davon aus dass er
natürlich heute schon höher sein wird
also tatsächlich es ist nur eine frage
der zeit wann diese variante die hoheit
übernehmen wird von den viren die in
unserem land kursieren und darum einmal
kurz eine zusammenfassung was wir an die
wissen über delta bislang geld heißt
noch ansteckender als alpha also die
variante die er im moment bei uns am
häufigsten vorkommt das heißt delta
verbreitet sich also noch schneller
vor allem natürlich in der ungeimpften
bevölkerung
daher müssen wir damit rechnen dass
künftig auch die fallzahlen wieder
steigen werden der großteil der fälle
ist bislang aufgetreten bei menschen
unter 60 jahre
die meisten ansteckungen passieren
momentan im privaten haushalt und es
gibt auch größere ausbrüche durch gelte
aber momentan noch wenige das heißt also
wir müssen damit rechnen dass es in
zukunft wieder etwas schwieriger wird
diesen ballon unter wasser zu halten
durch die dritte variante
wir wissen aber auch und das ist
wirklich wichtig zu verstehen dass alle
basis maßnahmen die wir kennen
beherrschen und durchführen dass alle
diese basismaßnahmen die ausbreitung von
gelten natürlich auch verhindern die
verhindern die ausbreitung jeder
variante
und zu diesen basis maßnahmen zählen
natürlich die asl riegeln das nutzen der
korona vanek und insbesondere das tragen
eines chirurgische mund nasen schutzes
die kontakt reduktion und wichtig ist
auch nach wie vor wenn die symptome
auftreten dass man dann bitte zu hause
bleibt und eben einen arzt an ruft aber
niemanden ansteckt dass man die test
gebote wahrnimmt wir haben wirklich eine
hervorragende test struktur in unserem
land und damit die gesundheitsämter nach
wie vor in ihre kontaktpersonen
nachverfolgen und quarantäne auf
maßnahmen aufrecht erhalten können und
wir wissen und das ist auch sehr wichtig
wir wissen dass menschen die vollständig
geimpft sind dass sie durch schon gegen
schwere erkrankung von delta geschützt
sind
das ist wirklich eine sehr sehr wichtige
gute nachricht aber ich betone es
nochmal der vollständigen impfschutz ist
wichtig die impfung bietet zwar keinen
100 prozentigen schutz aber auch
geimpfte menschen die ein aber nur
einmal geimpft sind können das virus vor
allem die immer noch weitergeben
das heißt also wirklich ist wichtig die
impfung zu vervollständigen
wir überprüfen ja im rkw ständig diese
neuen daten zu geld um die situation
besser einschätzen und bewerten zu
können und
das wird auch so bleiben über die
sommertage genauso also um es
zusammenzufassen die panini ist noch
nicht vorbei und die gefahr vor diesem
virus ist noch nicht gebannt
und darum müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass wir jetzt die inzidenz niedrig
halten das virus wird nicht mehr
verschwinden
es wird dann erst unter kontrolle sein
wenn ein großteil der menschen einen
immunschutz gegen das virus haben und
das erreichen wir wirklich am besten und
sichersten dadurch dass wir uns impfen
lassen die meisten menschen sind aber
noch nicht vollständig geben und bis ein
großteil vollständig geimpft wird wird
es auch noch eine weile dauern
und darum müssen wir in der zwischenzeit
die niedrigen instanzen die wir ja
gemeinsam erarbeitet haben in den
letzten monaten und die auch dank des
sommers so niedrig sind wir wissen ja
dass das virus eine gewisse saisonalität
hat darum lassen sie uns diese niedrigen
inzidenz wirklich verteidigen weiterhin
die residenz desto schwieriger wird es
auch für die varianten sich zu
verbreiten
und ich sage es nochmal das gilt für
delta genauso wie für alle weiteren
varianten die auch in der zukunft kommen
mögen
je niedriger die inzidenz ist je weniger
fälle kursieren desto besser sind auch
diejenigen geschützt
die noch nicht geimpft sind oder nicht
geimpft werden können
übernehmen sie übernehmen wir alle in
dem wir uns impfen lassen verantwortung
für uns selber aber auch für unsere
mitmenschen gerade die erwachsenen jede
impfung trägt dazu bei den anstieg der
fallzahlen im herbst möglichst flach zu
halten und die noch umkämpften zu
schützen zum beispiel viele kinder
natürlich jede versäumte impfungen aber
kann eben dazu führen dass der anstieg
im herbst steiler sein wird wenn wir es
schaffen viele zu impfen und die
inzidenz über den sommer niedrig zu
halten dann haben wir auch eine bessere
ausgangsposition für den herbst darum
nochmals mein appell wirklich lassen sie
uns die wiedergewonnene freiheit die wir
uns echt hart erkämpft haben nutzen die
inzidenz nötig halten immer noch impfen
basis infektionsschutz maßnahmen
inklusive tragen von chirurgischer mund
nasenschutz weiter war
auch bei niedrigen fallzahlen und nur
behutsame und kleinen schritten öffnen
diese maßnahmen sind weiterhin wichtig
und richtig gerade auch im hinblick auf
die sommerferien und wir alle wissen wir
möchten jetzt verreisen sehr viele
möchten verreisen aber wir befinden uns
eben immer noch in einer globalen
pandemie und natürlich ist mobilität ein
treiber dieser pandemie auf reisen hat
man in der regel viele kontakte
möglicherweise sogar mehr als sonst und
natürlich steigt dann mit kontakt nehmen
auch die chance das risiko dass man sich
ansteckt deshalb empfehlen wir vom
merkel ihn nach wie vor auf nicht nötige
reisen zu verzichten aber wir wissen
natürlich dass trotzdem verreist wird
und nun egal ob im in oder ausland
sie können sich auch dort schützen zum
einen informieren sich bitte gut über
die infektions lage dort wo sich ihnen
reisen und zum anderen geld natürlich
auch dort in der reisezeit die aha + l
regel tragen sie auch im urlaub im mund
nasenschutz natürlich insbesondere in
innenräumen und vermeiden sie auch im
urlaub
geschlossene räume mit schlechter
belüftung denn dort ist der virus
verbreitung einfacher vermeiden sie
menschenansammlungen gruppen mit dem
kontakte situationen erhöhen das
infektionsrisiko deutlich aber das
wissen sie das wissen wir alle und wenn
sie zurückkommen bitte nehmen sie die
testangebote war
wenn man in risikoregionen war gelten
ohnehin test und quarantäne regeln
bitte nehmen sie das weiter ernst damit
sie nicht im zweifelsfall andere
anstecken und lassen sie uns alle dazu
beitragen dass wir uns und unser umfeld
schützen damit sie gut durch den sommer
kommen und ich bedanke mich bei allen
die das weiterhin verantwortungsbewusst
tun ja guten morgen erfährt damen und
herren seit beginn der pandemie ist klar
dass ein sicherer und nachhaltiger
ausweg eine sichere rückkehr zur
normalität eigentlich nur über wirksame
impfstoffe funktioniert und die haben
wir glücklicherweise in rekordzeit
bekommen in kürze das hat man ist ja
sparen schon gesagt werden wir einen
erwachsenen ein impfangebot machen
können und das ist sehr erfreulich dass
heißt aber auch dass wir eine neue phase
der impfkampagne eintreten
und es ist essenziell dass für eine
möglichst hohe impfquoten erreichen wir
müssen also weiterhin gut aufklären gut
informieren und auch jene menschen
erreichen die aktuell noch zurückhaltend
sind oder noch unsicher sind oder die
vielleicht auch im hinblick auf die
jetzt erfreulich niedrigen instanzen
keine notwendigkeit mehr sehen sich
impfen zu lassen denn eins ist klar dass
kauf 2 wird eben nicht verschwinden es
wird weiter in der bevölkerung
zirkulieren und es wird immer wieder
zyklisch zu infektionswellen führen und
das können wir neben den kanten
maßnahmen eben nur durch eine sehr hohe
impfquoten erreichen damit können wir
die hohen fallzahlen verhindern und eben
auch die notwendigkeit für die
entsprechenden gegenmaßnahmen und die
verbreitung der data variante die wir
gehört haben den bisherigen
erkenntnissen zufolge eine erhöhte
infektiosität hat als die bisher
vorherrschende die ruß varianten die
wird mit ziemlicher sicherheit eine noch
höhere impfquote erfordern um diese
ziele zu erreichen
glücklicherweise bieten alle die in
deutschland zugelassenen impfstoffe
einen hervorragenden schutz vor allen
uns bekannten virusvarianten
insbesondere neueste daten aus
großbritannien zeigen dass eine
vollständige impfung einen fast
kompletten schutz vor schwere
erkrankungen und krankenhaus
behandlungen aufgrund von chromit 19
bietet allerdings und das ist auch schon
gesagt worden ist dazu eben eine
abgeschlossene imperial notwendig das
heißt man muss demnach für erstimpfung
eben auch den zweiten termin wahrnehmen
um einen vollständigen schutz zu haben
wir wissen auch dass die delta variante
so genannte flucht mutation enthält das
heißt sie es an einigen stellen so
verändert dass die schützende antikörper
die nach einer impfung ausgebildet
werden diese virus variante etwas
schlechter neutralisieren können das
heißt es kommt möglicherweise etwas
häufiger und das zeigen die zahlen aus
großbritannien zu sogenannten durchbruch
infektionen dass personen die
vollständig geimpft sind sich vielleicht
trotzdem anstecken
wichtig ist aber dass schwere
erkrankungen weiterhin verhindert werden
es ist auch so dass die allermeisten
menschen so hohe antikörper spiegel
haben
dass sich das dieser abschwächen effekt
gar nicht so schwer zum tragen kommt und
außerdem haben wir noch andere arme des
immunsystems zu die sogenannten t-zellen
die uns vor schwerer erkrankungen
schützen können personen die allerdings
ohnehin ein etwas abgeschwächt das
immunsystem oder abgeschwächte
immunantworten haben könnten
möglicherweise trotz impfung durch die
data variante wieder etwas stärker
gefährdet werden studien die unter
anderem an der charité durchgeführt
wurden haben gezeigt dass zum beispiel
ältere menschen über 80 jahre etwas
reduzierte immunantworten auch nach
vollständiger impfung aufweisen
gleichzeitig sind es aber ja die älteren
menschen die auf das höchste risiko für
schwere erkrankungen haben und aufgrund
der impf priorisierung als allererstes
in der impfkampagne geimpft wurden
dies in kombination mit der verbreitung
von virusvarianten die sogenannte flucht
mutationen enthalten könnte also zu
einem nachlassenden impfschutz führen
gerade bei wohlhabenden gruppen auch
nach borgen transplantation oder
bestimmten immunschwächen den therapien
haben werden abgeschwächte
immunantworten nach der elfen beobachtet
es fehlen aktuell daten die in
irgendeiner weise darauf hindeuten dass
sich diese menschen wieder vermehrt
infizieren das sind bisher
immunologische daten aus dem labor
aber ich denke die daten sollten wir
ernst nehmen und uns schon einmal darauf
vorbereiten dass für bestimmte
personengruppen im herbst und winter
gegebenenfalls eine auffrischungsimpfung
notwendig werden könnte
ich finde auch dass man über eine
auffrischungsimpfung gegebenenfalls für
personen nachdenken sollte die
kontaktpersonen sind zu diesen
risikogruppen wie zum beispiel teile des
gesundheitspersonals leider haben wir
aber bislang noch keine guten
studiendaten zur sogenannten booster
impfung solchen auffrischungsimpfungen
es gibt erste ergebnisse aus kleinen
untersuchungen die einen guten
auffrischung effekt einer dritten
impfung mit demselben impfstoff zeigen
auch die gabe eines an mutationen
angepassten impfstoff ist denkbar aber
aus meiner sicht nicht unbedingt
notwendig die bisher verfügbaren
impfstoffe scheinen hier einen sehr
guten effekt zu haben
in dem zusammenhang könnte man auch
darüber diskutieren so genannte
meteorologe kombinationen einzusetzen
das heißt dann mit einem
anderen impfstoff die dritte impfung zu
verabreichen auch dazu laufen einige
studien weltweit aber es gibt noch keine
guten erkenntnisse das heißt ich sehe da
auch eine gewisse dringlichkeit und
notwendigkeit dazu studien aufzulegen um
rasch diese erkenntnisse zu bekommen
welche kombination von booster impfungen
insbesondere risikogruppen effektiv sein
könnten
für eine generelle auffrischungsimpfung
auch vor dem hintergrund der delta
variante der gesamten bevölkerung sich
aktuell keinen anlass
zumal wir auch bedenken müssen dass
weite teile der weltbevölkerung noch
nicht einmal eine erste impfung bekommen
haben oder eben auch schwächere
impfstoffe zur verfügung haben als wir
sie glücklicherweise sich in deutschland
haben um eine rub um eine ruhe impfquote
mit entsprechenden effekten auf das
infektionsgeschehen zu erreichen wird
aus meiner sicht auch mittelfristig
notwendig seien kindern und jugendlichen
eine impfung anzubieten auch das hat
minister sparen gerade schon
angesprochen allerdings sehe ich
momentan auch mit der entwicklung der
delta variante noch den fokus darauf
möglichst eine möglichst hohe impfquoten
bei den erwachsenen menschen zu
erreichen
das heißt insgesamt sind die verfügbaren
impfstoffe die wir haben sicher und hoch
effektiv und bieten einen exzellenten
schutz auch vor den zirkulierenden virus
varianten inklusive der delta variante
allerdings lägen noch sehr große
herausforderungen vor uns
diese hohe im quote zu erreichen und
somit erneute anstieg in der kranken-
und todeszahlen im herbst und winter zu
verhindern und das und es könnte sein
dass auffrischungsimpfung bei bestimmten
personengruppen notwendig sind vielen
dank dafür ich habe bereits sieben
wortmeldungen hier im saal und
mindestens genauso viele noch einmal
online wir haben bis ungefähr um 11 uhr
zeit daher auch diese woche die bitte
sich auf eine kurze frage zu begrenzen
die dann auch hoffentlich möglichst kurz
beantwortet können werden kann
viele fragen online gibt es zum thema
auffrischungsimpfungen wozu wie eben
schon etwas gehört haben wir starten
aber im saal bei herrn winkel moment
immer noch falsch jetzt danke ersparen
meine frage an sie das heute entscheidet
ja nicht nur dass der bundesrat über die
pflege sondern das bundesarbeitsgericht
hat ein urteil gefällt über die kraft
aus dem was ich auch bereitschaftszeiten
den mindestlohn gezahlt bekommen und
auch wenn sie zu hause arbeiten was
folgt aus diesem urteil
legen sie ein neues gesetz vor was dafür
regelt was sagen sie als erwartungen an
die kosten also zuerst einmal ist das
thema der sogenannten 24 stunden
betreuung es geht ja nicht nur um pflege
sondern es geht um pflegekräfte aber
auch betreuungskräfte in den familien
für sehr viele familien millionen
familien wahrscheinlich ein sehr sehr
wichtiges ein sehr aktuelles was ihren
alltag auch betrifft zumindest mal auch
über ein jahr
weil es eben entsprechende unterstützung
auch gibt
der abgeordnete spahn hat ich weiß gar
nicht vor acht oder zehn jahren schon
mal vorschläge vorgelegt wie mit
besserer regulatorischer rahmen für 24
stunden kräfte gefunden werden könnte
die idee war und wäre aus meiner sicht
weiterhin vor allem auch sich das
österreichische vorbild anzuschauen
österreich hat genau für diese
arbeitssituation eine extra gesetzliche
regelung was arbeitsschutz und
arbeitszeit angeht geschaffen
bisher war das in der deutschen politik
und auch in der bundesregierung nicht
konsensfähig wenn wir noch einmal jetzt
auch im lichte dieses urteils in
gespräche miteinander kommen in beratung
finde ich ist das etwas was wir uns
anschauen sollten das bundesministerium
für gesundheit hat zudem in den letzten
drei jahren gutachten etwa bei professor
thüsing in auftrag gegeben und auch
ausgewertet anschließend zu der frage ob
und was man regeln und regulieren kann
auch immer
von eu arbeitszeit recht und dem
verfassungsrecht darüber haben wir auch
mit anderen ressorts gesprochen ich habe
heute morgen wahrgenommen dass der
bundesarbeitsminister gesagt hat er
sieht regelungsbedarf in diesem bereich
und wenn wir den gemeinsamen sehen
dann können wir ja auch gemeinsam an
einer lösung arbeiten also ich freue
mich dass es jetzt diese bewegung gibt
bis jetzt hieß es immer
es gebe kein regelungsbedarf aus dem
arbeitsministerium für 24 stunden kräfte
und ich finde den gibt es dafür ist das
thema zudringlich zum einen für die
familien aber eben auch für die
beschäftigten die natürlich auch ihre
rechte nicht nur kennen sollten sondern
eben auch umsetzen können sollten
insofern ist das ein urteil dass wir
jetzt erstmal in ruhe auswerten und dass
wir dann innerhalb der bundesregierung
wir sprechen ob es noch für gesetzgebung
ich habe gesagt es ist die letzte
sitzungswoche vor der sommerpause es ist
ja in wahrheit auch die letzte
gesetzgeberische sitzungswoche vor den
bundestagswahlen
das ist dann sicherlich ein gutes thema
und zwar zügig dann auch für die neue
bundesregierung und die neue
regierungskoalition weil dringlich dann
nehme ich jetzt mehr als nächste frage
zurück zum thema corona tatsächlich im
fragen zum thema auffrischungsimpfungen
und nehme mal drei fragen zusammen weil
die alle in eine ähnliche richtung
fragen junger blogger vom handelsblatt
fragt in die runde
empfehlen sie mit blick auf die delta
variante auch genießen eine zweite
impfung ist die erste frage
sascha meyer von dpa fragt ist es
vertretbar jetzt im abstände zu
verkürzen um schneller zum vollen schutz
gegen die data variante zu kommen
und als drittes gibt es die frage von
nadine eckert vom deutschen ärzteblatt
ein minister sparen was plant die
bundesregierung bezüglich
auffrischimpfungen also zuerst einmal
vielleicht kann er professor weder
professor sander vor allem auch mit
blick auf genesen und auffrischimpfung
oder zweifach impfung noch mal auch
ergänzen
zuerst einmal was plant was die
bundesregierung wir sind zum ersten auch
in dieser woche auf staatssekretärsebene
gab es eine runde mit den ländern über
die frage wie die infrastruktur nach dem
bis dahin ist jeder moment finanziert
die impfzentren auch erhalten werden
kann und vor allem was erhalten werden
muss und für uns ist ein ganz starker
augenmerk auf die mobilen teams sie
wissen dass wir die impfkampagne
begonnen haben vor allem auch in den
pflegeeinrichtungen und da sind ja teams
sozusagen aus den impfzentren
organisiert in die einzelnen
pflegeeinrichtungen die einrichtung der
behindertenhilfe für menschen mit
behinderung gegangen und haben dort vor
ort geimpft und mit blick auf das was
der professor sander gerade gesagt hat
dass eben besonders für immungeschwächte
ist sehr wahrscheinlich sehr viel sinn
macht vor herbst winter eine dritte eine
weitere auffrischimpfung zu machen ist
uns sehr wichtig dass wir diese mobilen
teams erhalten oder in vorbereitung
halten so ist es besser formuliert um
dann richtung herbst winter auch noch
mal ein solches weiteres impfangebot zu
machen und insgesamt was tun wir
zum zweiten ist ausreichend impfstoff
bereit halten wir werden ja wenn wir
allen ein angebot zuerst zweitimpfung
gemacht haben
ein teil der impfstoffe ja auch mit der
welt teilen können
auch andere teile der welt schon impfen
aber wir werden natürlich auch ein teil
der impfstoffe den wir in diesem jahr
noch erwarten uns bewahren für diese
möglichen auf frisch und booster impfung
um da auch auf alles vorbereitet zu sein
wir begleiten das ganze auch in studien
ein teil der studien der professor
sander angesprochen hat findet ihr auch
mit finanzieller unterstützung des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit statt
und es werden eben international die
studien ausgewertet ein letztes zudem
intervallen
wir haben von anfang an
eine impfstrategie gehabt die vorgesehen
hat die zweitimpfung innerhalb des
vorgesehenen in der zulassung
vorgesehenen intervalls das vereinigte
königreich hat auch aus durchaus ich
meine haben wir auch abgelegt aber aus
nachvollziehbaren gründen sich für einen
sehr starken fokus auf erstimpfungen
entschieden jetzt durch diese delta
variante fühlen wir uns jedenfalls auch
in dem in der strategie bestätigt die
zweitimpfung im intervall vorzusehen und
jetzt auch zügig eben zu ermöglichen in
diesem intervall und ich schlage auch
einfach vor dass wir innerhalb dieses
intervalls miteinander bleiben in
weiteren verlauf dieser ins kampagne
wenn stand heute gut 30 prozent erst
geimpft sind gut 50 prozent zweikämpfe
sind ist ja absehbar dass in vier bis
sechs wochen wir weit über 50 prozent
schon zwei kämpft haben werden aufgrund
der intervalle die da sind und dass das
jetzt eben auch zügig mit ansteigt also
hier innerhalb des intervalls
entscheiden dass am ende der impfen der
arzt und der zu impfenden weniger wissen
wir zum beispiel unsere länger der
abstand desto höher die wirksamkeit und
dann sind die dinge im medizinisch
miteinander abzuwägen
ja also ich denke leicht an da wird das
noch ergänzen aber noch mal wir haben in
glücklichen umstand dass wir in
deutschland eine stiko haben eine
ständige impfkommission die er
kontinuierlich die daten auswertet und
zwar systematisch mit systematischen
literatur reviews und dass dort eine
menge sachverstand reingeht und die
beobachten das und werden das weiter
analysieren und wir erwarten natürlich
auch von der stiko das entsprechende
empfehlungen kommen aber professor
sander hat es genau angesprochen
es sind eben noch nicht genügend daten
da wir wussten alle und wir haben das
auch alle immer wieder gesagt und
mitgeteilt dass es in eine
auffrischungsimpfung geben wird mit
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit aber wann der
zeitpunkt ist das können wir eben noch
nicht sagen das ist aber auch einfach zu
verstehen wenn wir erst seit ende des
letzten jahres impfen dann haben wir
natürlich den beobachtungszeitraum gar
nicht lang genug um das jetzt schon
sagen zu kommen das heißt der
beobachtungszeitraum ändert sich jeden
tag wird länger
die stiko wird
sprechen empfehlungen geben und es ist
auch abzusehen
es gibt eben gruppen von menschen die
ein insgesamt schwächeres immunsystem
haben und die stärker belastet sind und
es wird wahrscheinlich rein biologisch
ist das völlig nachvollziehbar so sein
dass es dann eventuell unterschiedliche
abschnitte gibt aber noch mal das ist
die entscheidung der stiko dafür werden
viele untersuchungen studien
durchgeführt und eben nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in anderen
ländern und ich möchte auch noch mal auf
die stiko hinweisen minister spahn
sprach es an genau dieser aspekt ein
grund warum die stiko sich in
deutschland explizit nicht dafür
ausgesprochen hatte im winter vale zu
kürzen und wir als entschuldigung
integrale zu verlängern war genau einer
der sorgen die jetzt eingetreten ist
dass es nämlich varianten geben wird die
gewisse flucht mutationen haben und
dieses ausbilden von varianten ist
leichter wenn ein größerer teil der
population keinen vollen schutz hat als
den vollen impfschutz das heißt also
auch da ist die strategie die richtige
gewesen
und insofern werden wir uns weiter auf
die stiko verlassen können und es ist
ein lebendes review eine lebende
empfehlung und immer wieder dass die
stiko die anpassen dann kann ich mich im
wesentlichen anschließen
ich glaube die gabe der 2000 signal bis
zugelassen ein intervall es ist richtig
wir haben unser zeit glücklicherweise
niedrige zahlen das heißt wir können
auch mit ruhe einfach so weiter machen
die das bisher auch empfohlen ist und er
auch gut ist und die daten im übrigen
aus england zum beispiel für die
astrazeneca impfungen sind ja eben mit
dem intervall von zwölf wochen die aber
zeigen dass ist in der weise dann
wirksam wir wissen aber nicht wenn wir
das auf einmal drastisch verkürzen
ob wir damit dann an wirksamkeit
verlieren das wollen wir ja auch nicht
haben
zu der frage ob genesene sich noch
einmal auffrischen lassen sollten
ich glaube das kann man nicht in einen
topf werfen eine genesen ein genesener
das ist nicht das ist nicht dasselbe
weil die auch die da gibt es hochbetagte
die sich vielleicht angesteckt haben da
beginnen wir erst die daten zu bekommen
wie sich auch der dauer eines solchen
schutzes verhält ich glaube eine junge
person die sich angesteckt hat und dann
einmalig dürfte ist das zeigen die daten
die haben einen hervorragenden
immunschutz die sind in der regel besser
geschützt als personen die zweimalige
mehr an einen stoff geimpft sind von der
sehe ich da noch nicht die dringlichkeit
aber vielleicht bei den wirklich älteren
personen sollte man auch da noch mal
hinsehen und die vielleicht generell ich
glaube das macht keinen sinn
irgendwelche antikörpertest oder
ähnliches zu machen sondern damit einem
augenmaß was man weiß welche
altersgruppen sind gefährdet daneben
eine auffrischungsimpfung sowie von
minister spann skizziert vorzunehmen
anbieten können jedenfalls auch von der
menge des zur verfügung stehenden
impfstoffes ist dass jemand der für sich
für zusätzliche sicherheit mit einem
gewissen abstand die dritte impfung
möchte unabhängig von einer empfehlung
sie auch bekommen kann
also werden sie jedenfalls möglich
machen können und dann kann neben der
genesene der zumindest dann sagt möchte
aber nach sechs monaten noch mal auch
eine zusätzliche sicherheit haben oder
nach zwölf sie auch bekommen dann machen
wir im saal weiter bei froh wolf vielen
dank
sparen sie wiesen eingehen darauf hin
dass man von cash angebot beim reisen
gebrauch machen soll jetzt erst wieder
zur diskussion ob das beste die schieben
bei den reifen nicht verschärft werden
sollen beispielsweise dieses modell mit
negativ fest ankommen vor ort am
flughafen testen lassen danach nochmal
ppr um das amt zu bestätigen
trainieren sie dafür darf tatsächlich
auszuweiten auch für reisen innerhalb
europas und zwar vielleicht auch über
die also zuerst einmal haben wir uns
erstmal wenn noch mal kurz zurück
schondorf auf zusammen letzten jahr das
man kann sich das gar nicht mehr
vorstellen aber wir hatten im letzten
sommer nur pcr tests im labor zur
verfügung und auch nur eine kapazität
die weniger als die hälfte war der
heutigen also in wahrheit eine völlig
andere situation auch was test kapazität
test verfügbarkeit angeht als heute
wir haben diese frage ja mit den
gesundheitsminister innenministern der
länder beraten zu einem gemeinsamen
empfehlung geführt erste die testpflicht
vor abflug aus dem ausland nach
deutschland für jeden reisenden egal aus
welchem land aufrecht zu erhalten es
gibt nicht wenige die sagen dann schafft
das doch auch bei nicht risikogebieten 1
für zusätzliche sicherheit während
dieser reise
werden wir diese tests pflicht vor dem
boarding im abflugort aufrecht ein
zweiter teil ist ja wie weiterhin
vorzunehmende qualifizierung oder
eingruppierung risikogebiet hoch
inzidenz gebiet wehres varianten gebiet
und mir ist einfach mal wichtig auch bei
rückkehr aus einem risikogebiet gilt
grundsätzlich quarantäne zehn tage außer
man zeigt aktiv seinem gesundheitsamt
seiner gesundheitsbehörde ein negativ
test also ist auch aus einem
risikogebiet braucht es weiterhin eben
eine entsprechende negativ testung
aktuell um die quarantäne zu beenden
beim hoch incidents gebiet geht das
frühestens nach fünf tagen beim
virusvarianten gebiet geht das gar nicht
das sei auch allen gesagt die unbedingt
gegebenenfalls was von ich nicht werben
kern abraten wollen würde nach england
reisen wollen wer zurückkommt muss zwei
wochen in quarantäne und das macht sehr
deutlich im zweifel in einer hoch und
enden virusvarianten gebiet nicht fahren
bitte wenn man nicht unbedingt dann auch
muss und dann haben wir ihnen zusätzlich
die kostenlosen test angebote
flächendeckend für alle reisenden so wie
es letztes jahr ja auch hatten das
angebot letztes jahr war jeder zurück
reisende kann sich testen lassen egal
aus welchem gebiet und welche
risikosituation und ich kann halt nur
ermuntern und dazu auffordern das auch
zu tun
wir können ja in wahrheit wenn keine
insel wir können ja in wahrheit jetzt
nicht jeden einreisenden nach
deutschland kommen selbst fahre ich
nachher wieder hin an die
niederländische grenze von der
niederländischen grenze bin ich zu hause
wir können nicht jeden tag da jeden
einreisenden eine testpflicht
unterliegen lassen die wir kontrollieren
könnten deswegen ist gerade beim reisen
neben den test pflichten und quarantäne
pflichten die ich angesprochen habe eben
auch eigenverantwortung und das
aufeinander aufpassen sehr wichtig hohe
impfquoten drückt sie das zunehmend also
wir beobachten ja viele länder in der
welt und was wir beobachten ist
natürlich dass impfungen schützen
wir beobachten aber auch dass es
unterschiedliche effektivität gibt und
die impfstoffe die bei uns zugelassen
sind haben eine hohe effektivität aber
was das lehrt und das ist gut dass sie
das noch mal fragen
diese impfungen alleine werden uns nicht
vor einem anstieg im herbst schützen
also impfungen alleine senken natürlich
die anzahl der fallzahlen der
erkrankungsfälle und auf der schweren
verläufe aber die impfung alleine
reichen eben nicht aus und man hat jetzt
teilweise länder wo man dann viele
maßnahmen zurückgenommen hat und ich
rede vor allen dingen von diesen
basismaßnahmen also dass man zb in
geschlossenen räumen einen mund nasen
schutz trägt das man test konzepte hat
nehmen wir zum beispiel die schulen in
schulen test konzepte um infizierte früh
zu erkennen ist nach wie vor wichtig
also die lehre aus diesen aus diesen
fakten die wir dort sehen ist dass man
nicht zu früh lockern sollte ungezielt
lockern sollte sondern dass man diesen
gesang ja also diesen erfolg den wir
zusammen und wirklich hart erarbeitet
haben und auch eine menge opfer dafür
gebracht haben dass wir den verteidigen
wir müssen die basismaßnahmen weiter
aufrechterhalten
ich weiß dass das sehr schwierig ist ich
kriege selber sehr viele anfragen
diesbezüglich gerade von eltern die
sagen warum soll mein kind mein junge
mit mund nasenschutz in der schule
sitzen wir wieder das kann ich kein meer
ich kann das einerseits verstehen
andererseits ist dieser mund nasenschutz
ein wirklich sehr sehr sehr wenig
aufwendiges mittel viel zu erreichen
aber er hilft eben nur wenn alle den
mund nasenschutz in innenräumen tragen
und nochmal wir haben wirklich jetzt
gute testsysteme wir können auch
inzwischen aufgrund der hohen kapazität
von pcr tests wir haben über zwei
millionen kapazität können wir auch in
schulen übrigens auch in schulen
universitäten da gibt es auch einige
konzepte wirklich guten test konzepte
fahren um infizierte früh genug zu
erkennen das heißt also impfen alles was
möglich ist um die impfungen zu
unterstützen
genau der wichtige punkt genug impfstoff
vor reicht werden und genug
infrastruktur vorratsdaten um auch
dorthin zu kommen wo leute die
vielleicht nicht so intensiv impfen
lassen aufsuchen lebens gebiete und die
kombination aus einer basis maßnahme und
der impfung die wollen wir damit wir
eben keine situation mehr haben wo wir
wieder maßnahmen fahren müssen die
bevölkerung bezogen sind also sowas wie
also schließungen von bestimmten einigen
das wollen wir alle nicht und wir können
es aber nur vermeiden wenn wir beides
parallel machen basismaßnahmen und
impfungen und das beispiel israel zeigt
dass man es machen muss man muss bei sis
weiterfahren
daher kann ich dazu noch ergänzen wir
haben ja in israel erstaunlich früh
erfreulicherweise diese effekte der
impfung gesehen früher als man das
vielleicht hätte erwarten können
bei einer impfquote um die 50 prozent
gab schon deutliche effekte und
eigentlich können wir ein bisschen was
aus israel lernen weil dann natürlich
relativ früh dann jetzt auch gelockert
wurde und die kombination aus lockerung
und dann jetzt einer anderen variante
führt eben dazu dass dann so eine
impfquote auch nicht mehr ganz ausreicht
um das infektionsgeschehen zu
kontrollieren von daher kann ich das nur
unterstützen dass wir wirklich besser
informieren da reingehen und die
impfquote muss dann wahrscheinlich noch
ein bisschen höher werden aber
beunruhigend ist es nicht ist er leer
reichlich sagen aus meiner sicht weil
israel sondern ist ja eins
berücksichtigen ist ein relativ junges
land sehr vielen kindern jugendlichen
und jungen menschen wir sind ein
vergleichsweise älteres land aber es
zeigt sich im trotzdem wenn die
impfbereitschaft bei denen die sich
impfen lasse
können auch den 20 oder 25 jährigen
nicht hoch genug ist das sehen wir
gerade die umfragen zeigen ja
tatsächlich in deutschland die
impfbereitschaft steigt mit dem alter
aus vielen nachvollziehbaren gründen im
zweifel aber ich kann ihnen nur dafür
werben auch bei jüngeren das impfangebot
geben auch wahrzunehmen um sich selbst
zu schützen aber eben auch uns alle zu
schützen auch das zeigt israel zum thema
reisen nämlich noch eine frage dazu die
frank jordan stellt von ap erfragt
minister sparen und herren wieder die
kanzlerin sehr gestern mit ihrem versuch
eine einheitliche eu regel bei einreisen
aus drittstaaten die virusvarianten
gebiete sind durchzusetzen gescheitert
was bedeutet das für die verlangsamung
der einschleppung weiterer fälle der
data variante nach deutschland jetzt
zuerst einmal ist es aus meiner sicht
immer wünschenswert dass wir innerhalb
der europäischen union innerhalb unseres
traums auch des freien reisens der
freien mobilität zur einheitlichen
regelungen kommen
ich bedauere ist dass das zum einen bei
virusvarianten gebieten aber auch bei
der frage was geht mit welchen impfungen
nicht bisher gelungen ist trotz aller
bemühungen bei virusvarianten gebieten
heißt er schlicht und ergreifend dass
wir weiterhin unsere maßnahmen daneben
auch national entscheiden müssen
wir hätten sie gerne stärker abgestimmt
mit anderen europäischen partnern
viele machen es ja ähnlich wie wir aber
eben nicht alle
und jetzt habe ich gerade erwähnt dass
ich von der niederländischen grenze
kommen also amsterdam ist repol der
flughafen ist eine stunde von mir
zuhause berlin ist 5 natürlich ist die
frage
einer führte uns mit dem content
inmitten geografisch in diesem kontinent
liegend schon auch eine was passiert um
uns herum bei der einreise aus
virusvarianten gebieten das müssen wir
einfach mit dem blick haben
auch die entwicklung in diesen
jeweiligen ländern und schauen wie dort
die machen wir jede woche regelmäßig
schauen wird es nochmal auch erinnern
kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem
gesundheitsministerium aus dem
auswärtigen amt dem innenministerium mit
unterstützung des robert koch instituts
und den botschaften in sozusagen die
jeweiligen länder in die situation der
länder und machen jetzt gerade heute
nachmittag ja erneut die eingruppierung
und da schauen wir natürlich sehr genau
auch wie sich die varianten auch in den
europäischen nachbarländern entwickeln
und ob daraus maßnahmen folgen also
kurzzusammenfassung es wäre besser
gewesen wir würden eu einheit nicht dort
regeln finden wenn nicht müssen wir
weiterhin unsere machen um uns zu
schützen
ja ich dass das ist so ich kann es nur
sagen wir jetzt mal aus einem anderen
aspekt noch mal unterstreichen also was
wir in deutschland auch gelernt haben
die sie kennen diese kosmos studie die
zeigt eigentlich sehr schön dass die
akzeptanz der menschen natürlich steigt
damit wenn die maßnahmen einheitlich
gefahren werden das gilt natürlich für
europa genauso gut wie viel deutschland
auch für die einzelnen bundesländern
das heißt einheitliche maßnahmen in
einem bestimmten geografischen raum
erhöhen die compliance der mitmenschen
das ist ein aspekt der wissenschaftlich
fundiert ist und das alleine ist einer
der gewichtiger grund warum es einfach
besser wäre
abgesehen davon dass man eben auch
einfach durcheinander kommt und nicht
mehr genau weiß wo man was zu tun hat
aber die compliance wird verbessert das
ist wissenschaftlich wirklich wichtig zu
wissen haben übrigens erst mal nicht die
situation dass alle länder um uns herum
gleich gelb sind also gleich wenig
infektionen an sonst hatten wir immer
tschechische republik frankreich oder
wir immer bei einer schwer betroffen in
den letzten monaten jetzt sind wir mal
alle gleich niedrig da sollten wir
versuchen uns lange zu erhalten
wir machen im saal weiter mit frei
gefahren der kollege sebastian habe ich
von euch die trotz ersparen hört sich
nach umfragen erschienen im auftrag der
generationen stiftung die nach seinem
zweiten jahr der krise 84 prozent der
menschen unter 26 der ansicht die
regierung missachte ihre interessen ist
jetzt bei leider auch nicht die erste
umfrage mit dieser mit diesem ergebnis
was antworten sie auf diese weit
verbreitete ansicht bei jüngeren
menschen dass ich immer nur wieder dafür
erstmal immer wieder das gespräch suche
das ist digital natürlich schwieriger
möglich ist kommen wir wieder in die
möglichkeit zumindest unter bestimmten
bedingungen miteinander auch direkt zu
reden aber ich find's einfach wichtig
miteinander zu reden und das entsteht ja
diese wahrnehmung man die interessen
würden nicht wahrgenommen nicht gesehen
das steht ja einfach aus einer situation
heraus und die kann man nur sich
gegenseitig verstehen warum wird was
entschieden warum ist ja auch ein
starker schwerpunkt mit diesem virus auf
dem schutz der älteren und gleichzeitig
eben wo er sozusagen auch dieses diese
wahrnehmung kommt die die interessen der
jüngeren wären ich sage das ausdrücklich
imperiales wäre nicht im blick natürlich
ist das das wort um wir jeden tag ringen
diesen ausgleich zu finden und schule
und kita das zum beispiel aber auch die
universitäten ausbildung im übrigen ja
auch die berufsschulen
das war seit der ersten
ministerpräsidenten konferenz der
professor wähler war ja bei der
allerersten auch mit dabei märz 2020 wo
wir das thema so stark im fokus hatten
seit dieser ersten runde bund länder
sind diese fragen mit das hauptthema und
wird darum gerungen
also es ist und war auf jeden fall im
blick
und trotzdem muss uns ja beschäftigen
und beschäftigt auf mich die frage war
wie es dann zu einem solchen eindruck
kommen keine was wir tun können um auch
ein angebot zu machen wohl tatsächlich
auch klar ist wir haben das natürlich im
blick und das gilt für mich zum beispiel
eben auch das impfangebot mir war es
wichtig und ist es auch wichtig dass zum
beispiel an auch den universitäten wie
hier in berlin gerade geschehen auch im
fang geboten niedrigschwellig gemacht
werden so wie wir sie in den betrieben
machen sollen sie eben auch zum beispiel
in universitäten möglich sein und da wo
junge menschen und vor allem ist man
nicht auch die über 18-jährigen junge
menschen auch sind um sie zu schützen
ist ein aspekt ein fokus die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen die
wirtschaftlichen unterstützungsmaßnahmen
die es ja auch gegeben hat und anderes
mehr
aber das wichtigste ist eben vor allem
miteinander im gespräch zu sein und ich
hoffe das kann jetzt etwas besser wieder
möglich sein als nur per video konferenz
die entferntesten daran was muss ich da
konkret noch weil der eindruck ist nach
wie vor stark verbreitet ja dieser
generationengerechtigkeit wir junge ich
bespitzelt mal haben die älteren
geschützt und bekommen jetzt nichts
dafür dass jetzt wieder
ich weiß sie sagen sie sind da
missverstanden worden aber wechsel unter
richtige die rede und so weiter und so
fort der eindruck bleibt ja bestehen
also was muss da anders werden aus ihrer
sicht die frage ist ja was heißt jetzt
die bekommen nichts dafür setzt eine
frage der sozusagen wie gehen wir da
rein
also ich jedenfalls erlebe familien in
deutschland und auch auf der welt so
dass man wenn man seine großeltern
schützt dafür nicht nur was am will also
so erlebe ich nicht familie
es ist doch irgendwie das aufeinander
aufpassen um mein eindruck ist aus den
gesprächen die und auch im übrigen aus
umfragen dass die bereitschaft und der
wille auf die großeltern und eltern
generation in dieser pandemie auch
besonders acht zu geben weil besonders
gefährdet ich meine es könnte ja auch
mal ein virus leider längst kommen wo
die 20 oder 10 jährigen besonders
gefährdet sind ist ja nicht
auszuschließen
das virus macht das ja so dass wir eben
eine bestimmte altersgruppe besonders
schützen müssen einfach auch für unser
aller wohl und trotzdem eben die anderen
belangen nicht aus dem blick verlieren
dass das ist ja dieses tägliche ringen
um balance und das abwägen
unterschiedliche aspekte und wenn sie
fragen was kann man machen ich finde das
allerwichtigste
es ist jedenfalls meine art politik zu
machen seitdem ich politik mache einfach
auch miteinander im gespräch zu sein und
das will ich jetzt auch wieder stärker
tun wo es auch wieder stärker möglich
ist ob es eben um schulen geht um
universitäten oder generell um das leben
auch von jüngeren in deutschland ein
weiter grund für niedrige inzidenz man
kann auch wieder mehr miteinander
sprechen vor ort herr reitschuster hat
die nächste frage sparen der
bundestags-vizepräsident kubicki von der
fdp hat gesagt die strategie der
bundesregierung sei durch fortdauernde
schreckensnachrichten angst zu erzeugen
nun hat herr kekulé in einem gastbeitrag
geschrieben dass die delta variante zwar
ansteckender sei aber es ist eigentlich
zu gefährlich wird die aktuelle variante
er sagte wörtlich die eignet sich nicht
für schreckensszenarien wie ist da ihre
eigene schätzung danke also wir
berichten ja immer nüchtern sachlich
über die fakten die uns zur verfügung
stehen
und sobald diese dinge sich dann
bestätigen das heißt also durch vor
allem publikationen die auch in einem so
genannten peer review verfahren sind
wenn die von uns berichtet also ich kann
ihnen folgendes transfer delta variante
aber das sind wirklich wir haben noch
nicht genügend daten um wirklich klar zu
sagen wie gefährlich oder ungefährlich
oder wie vergleichbar sie ist aber ich
kann ihn mal die daten aus deutschland
jetzt nur nennen haben in deutschland so
seit der elfter oder so 13 woche haben
wir delta variante und wir haben schon
viel länger die alpha variante wir
können also in bestimmten zeitraum also
einige wochen auf jeden fall elfte bis
24 woche können wir so vergleichen und
dann sehen wir dass momentan und das was
ich jetzt sage sind die zahlen aus dem
mehl gewesen also das heißt die zahlen
die von den gesundheitsämtern uns
gemeldet werden
da sehen wir das also dass insgesamt bei
jüngeren menschen vorkommt aber das ist
natürlich klar dass die impfquote steigt
dann sind natürlich mehr jüngere
betroffen wo die impfquote noch so
geringer sind
aber wir sehen bei vergleichbaren
altersgruppen die infiziert sind das bei
der delta variante momentan
stand vorgestern elf prozent derjenigen
die infiziert wurden werden
hospitalisiert die mit delta infiziert
wurden im vergleichs raum wurden fünf
prozent derjenigen hospitalisiert die
mit alpha infiziert worden also ist erst
mal eine zahl also momentan kann ich das
nicht bestätigen momentan deuten unsere
meldezahlen dahinter ist also quasi
doppelt so hoch die hospitalisierung
skate ist das ist einfach eine zahl an
fakt in den werden wir weiter beobachten
was vor allen dingen auch bemerkenswert
ist das ist wenn wir uns die
altersgruppe zwischen 15 und 34 als
wirklich junge menschen anschauen
dort ist das besonders stark ausgeprägt
das ist jetzt ein fakt den ich ihn
berichten kann und insofern gibt es
moment aus meiner sicht und natürlich
gibt es noch andere daten
vielleicht kann es anders aus denn es
gibt ja gerade an vereinten königreich
sie sprechen eigentlich nicht dafür dass
delta vielleicht weniger gefährlich wäre
als als alpha sondern auch die sprechen
eher für das gegenteil aber wie gesagt
das sind ja alles noch sehr junge daten
wie wir das weiter beobachten sondern
daten vielleicht noch höher sein als
politisch da gibt es gerade eine große
studie die jetzt auch veröffentlicht und
nehmen auch begutachtet im fachjournal
the lancet die eben aus schottland
berichtet wo durchaus mal vergleicht
personen die sich mit einer delta
variante angesteckt haben vergleich mit
der variante auch wie in deutschland
mehr leute ins krankenhaus müssen
das ist im prinzip einfach jetzt eine
beobachtung und ich glaube man kann
jetzt nicht sagen dies sei einfach eine
harmlosere variante das was wir
hoffentlich sehen ist dass wir
infektionen immer weiter sage ich mal
aus den sehr hohen rebellengruppen raus
halten können und dass deswegen dann
glücklicherweise weniger leute
versterben das haben wir schon in der
dritten welle mit der alpha variante
sehen können dass wir weniger alte
menschen auf der intensivstation hatten
und deswegen noch mal der appell wenn
wir uns impfen dann können wir auch
solchen möglicherweise ansteckenden
gefährlicheren varianten standhalten
wissen sie ich frage mich immer was was
sozusagen die einstellung dahinter ist
so was wie warum sollte die
bundesregierung baby war das wort mit
mit solchen szenarien arbeiten also die
frage ist was ist eigentlich die
unterstellung dahin
da mache ich mich dann immer ich bin ich
bin echt ein freiheitsliebender mensch
bin so so super dankbar in einem der
reichsten länder der welt zu leben
glaubt ihr ehemann wir haben freude
daran freiheiten einzuschränken
also ich frage mich immer was soll diese
unterstellung dahinter eigentlich heißen
ich möchte dass wir so schnell wie
möglich wieder in eine situation kommen
dass jeder frei seine sachen tun kann
ohne dass irgend etwas eingeschränkt
wird weder gewerbebetriebe eingeschränkt
werden einzelhandel eingeschränkt wird
die frage ob man feiern kann sich
treffen keine schule sich bilden kann
alles soll wieder möglich sein aber eben
unter sicheren bedingungen für die
gesellschaft was auch die gesundheit
angeht denn auch die gesundheit gehört
zur freiheit was hilft einem die
schönste freiheit wenn feder krank sind
dabei oder man selber vielleicht auch so
und das ist diese diese balance um die
wir ringen und wenn einer ja erlebt das
ringen dann ja jemand der über viele
stunden über diese debatten wacht er
jeden tag gerungen darum und was wir
machen ist wir sagen einfach wie es ist
und beschreiben die abwägungen die
daraus folgen und die entscheidung die
aus unserer sicht aus diesen abwerbungen
folgen
und was mehrheit am wichtigsten ist dass
wir das wirklich unter grosser härte
verlusten schmerzen erreichte jetzt ende
juni miteinander erreichte dass wir das
sichern was nützt es uns denn wenn wir
jetzt alle weil wir so das gefühl haben
sommer gutes wetter das gefühl habe ich
auch aber jetzt hilft uns ja nichts wenn
wir jetzt so tun als wäre das weg es ist
nicht weg ist noch da und ich finde es
gehört zur verantwortung in der politik
dazu dann die dinge auch auszusprechen
und eben zu sagen miteinander
es liegt an uns leute ob wir das
erreichte sichern
ob herbst und winter gezeigt werden wo
wir die dinge besser unter kontrolle
haben oder eben nicht
und da finde ich solche kategorien wie
sie sie eingangs genannt haben nicht
hilfreich für eine gute diskussion
zu ihrer gegenfrage was solche
unterstellung müssen sie herrn kubicki
fragen ich gehe davon aus dass er sich
auf das strategiepapier des
innenministeriums bezieht wo explizit
von im schüren von angst die rede war
können sie auch nachlesen
aber die nachfrage sie hatten ja immer
die maßnahmen damit gerechtfertigt dass
vor allem die wohlhabenden gruppen
geschützt werden müssen die
risikogruppen jetzt haben selbst
experten hier gesagt die impfung schützt
auch gegen älter werden damit die
variablen gruppen geschützt sind warum
dann weiter massnahmen danke zuerst
haben es gibt zwei aspekte und das wird
übrigens nicht sehr schwierige debatte
die wir miteinander werden führen müssen
in den nächsten wochen
der anteil der geimpften und er
vollständig geschützten steigt aber er
ist eben nicht so hoch dass sozusagen
gar nichts mehr an infektionsgeschehen
da ist und die frage ist wie finden wir
da die richtige balance des hat zwei
aspekte das eine ist ein sehr
individueller aspekt wenn jedem einen
impf eine impfung angeboten worden ist
hat dann eigentlich derjenige der sich
nicht impfen lässt einen anspruch darauf
dass alle anderen im raum die geimpft
sind wegen ihm die maske tragen oder
wegen er grundsätzlich aus dem
individuellen aspekten nicht wer sich
hat schützen können kann nicht erwarten
dass alle anderen jetzt ihn oder sie
dann besonders schützen und immer alle
maßnahmen sozusagen nur darauf bezog ist
es individuelle aspekt aber es kommt ein
zweiter dazu und das ist seit beginn
dieser pandemie unser hauptaspekt eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
vermeiden
und darum und das macht das
robert-koch-institut wie andere auch
aber das robert-koch-institut ja auch
für uns in unserem auftrag und wir
besprechen das regelmäßig natürlich auch
miteinander und das werden wir jetzt im
juli hat auch noch mal miteinander
gemeinsam auf herbst und april herbst
und sommer herbst und winter schauen ist
ja die frage was heißt das wenn in
deutschland 70 oder 80 prozent geimpft
sind dahin müssen wir erst mal kommen
ich hoffe es machen viele mit das heißt
das wenn die über 60 jährigen zum
größten teil geimpft sind die 20 30 40
jährigen aber vielleicht nur zu einem
geringeren teil
was heißt das wenn dann
einfach ohne jede maßnahme zirkulierte
was heißt das dann für das
gesundheitswesen das heißt das für den
einzelnen aber auch für das
gesundheitswesen das kann man ja alles
zumindest mit annahmen modellieren ist
immer wichtig keine vorhersagen sind
modelle mit annahmen und das ist das was
uns bewegt und beschäftigt das eine wie
gesagt dieser individuelle aspekt wo ich
eine sehr klare meinung habe wie sie
gerade gehört haben
das andere ist und da bin ich als
bundesminister für gesundheit ist das
jedenfalls einer meiner wendig seit
beginn der pandemie der hauptfokus die
überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
vermeiden und das will ich erstmal dann
auch miteinander er geleitet haben dass
wir eine impfquote erreicht haben bei
der das gegeben ist ich habe noch vier
fragen hier im saal auf der liste und
noch ich glaube drei aspekte online das
würde ich noch gerne schaffen und ihr
kollege der gerade nach den
ausländischen pflegekräften frage sei
der hinweis gegeben dass hatten wir
gleich als erste frage vielleicht kann
er das nachschauen
ich nehme jetzt mal wieder drei fragen
zusammen die alle nach dem digitalen ins
nachweis fragen
charlotte kurz von der pharmazeutischen
zeitung fragt auf welche summe soll die
vergütung für die erzeugung der
digitalen corvette 19 impfen nachweise
ab wann sinken gleiche frage gibt es
auch von apotheke adhoc und dann gibt es
zwei fragen zu technischen details die
erste frage thomas rommel von der ärzte
zeitung fragt genesene bekommen nur eine
impfung voraussetzung für den digitalen
impfnachweis ist die auffrischung mit
der zweiten impfung wie und wann
schließen sie die regelungslücke und
winnie heescher vom zdf fragt es gibt
mehrere zehntausend menschen die im
vergangenen frühjahr corona hatten aber
von den gesundheitsämtern keine pcr
tests bekommen haben
die bekommen nun mit einer impfung und
antikörper nachweis keinen digitalen
impfpass was tun sie dagegen
also zur letzten frage ist die antwort
dann ist eine zweite impfung notwendig
um den vollständigen impfschutz zu haben
diese übrigen auch unproblematisch
diese zweite impfung aber eben notwendig
weil nur die pcr test einen
antikörpertest alleine auf fink mögliche
aktivitäten von anderen coronaviren gibt
keine aber das können sie im zweifel rät
ihre ehe mit dem professor wieder
regelmäßig keine regelmäßige aussage
darüber deswegen frage war was tun
zweite impfung in dem fall was die frage
angeht genesene im digitalen ins
zertifikat ist unser ziel bis ende juni
anfang juli möglichst bald auch dort das
entsprechende release wie es heißt also
update der app so zu haben dass auch das
abgebildet werden kann wir wollten nur
nicht warten mit der app insgesamt bis
auch der teil vollends aus entwickelt
ist an der stelle da bitte ich einfach
um geduld und verständnis ich bin selbst
ein betroffener davon ich habe es auch
noch nicht auf meinem handy wahl gewesen
und das eben noch nicht geht wir tun
alles dafür dass es bald geht die frage
der vergütung fürs digitale im
zertifikat im moment stellen die
apotheken übrigens etwa eine million im
zertifikate digital am tag heraus
wir haben gesagt mit einer höheren
vergütung zu beginn ich bin sehr dankbar
und das war auch sehr wichtig dass die
apotheken von anfang an mitgemacht haben
das war ja auch durchaus eine diskussion
ob das so sein soll oder nicht
oder es hat geholfen dass vor allem auch
die bereits geimpften und ich sie
regelmäßig auf meinem weg morgens ins
ministerium schon am frühen morgen
teilweise vor den apotheken leute die
erkennbar rauskommen und rein wollen um
das digitale zertifikat auch zu erhalten
also dass viele das nutzen ist erstmal
gut
deswegen haben wir für den anfang auch
für die schulung für das was neue
software oder neue programme immer ein
ärger macht und zeitaufwand eine höhere
vergütung vorgesehen
wir wollen sie auf 6 euro wie für alle
anderen auch senken
anfang juli ich kann das jetzt noch
nicht auf den tag sagen aber es wird
eben jetzt dann dass ein können aus
meiner sicht auch weil tatsächlich der
anfangs aufwand und die an
investitionen auch entsprechend dann
berücksichtigt sind und wenn man sieht
dass wir es für die abgabe eines
medikamentes auch knappe sieben euro
gibt glaube ich ist das auch eine preis
größenordnung mit der gut umgegangen
werden kann
dann machen wir ein jahr weiter auf der
von uns aus gesehen rechten seite vielen
dank claudia plastal der hauptstadt
studio eine frage an sie herr minister
und eine frage an sie herr minister ich
möchte noch mal zurückkommen auf die
ausländischen pflegekräfte ist werden
jetzt einmal mehr gerade nach dem urteil
forderungen nach einer pflege
bürgerversicherung laut wie bewerten sie
das und herr wieder könnten sie noch mal
ganz konkret sagen wie sollen sich denn
die schulen jetzt aus ihrer sicht frau
bereit sie hatten vorhin angesprochen
aber vielleicht dass hier noch mal ganz
konkret sagen können jetzt in den
sommerferien was muss in den schulen
getan werden
auch gerade vor dem hintergrund der sich
ausbreitenden data variante dankeschön
es scheint ja kein thema zu geben dass
man nicht doch irgendwann dann mit
seinem ideologischen ziel einer
einheitsversicherung verbinden können
kann also das habe ich jetzt vorhin auch
im ticker gelesen das nehmen wir zur
kenntnis dass trifft aber doch den
pflege- und betreuungskräfte aus dem
ausland ich wenn wir in deutschland eine
bürgerversicherung einheitsversicherung
einführen um es doch geht ist die
refinanzierung und die pflegereform in
ihrer ganzen breite die ich vorgelegt
hatte im herbst letzten jahres hat
regelung vorgesehen etwa auch einer
möglichen refinanzierung aus dem
pflegegeld pflegesachleistungen für 24
stunden kräfte um zum beispiel familien
zu entlasten
das war ein teil der nicht hat geeinigt
werden können jetzt bei dem was heute
beschlossen wird was heute beschlossen
wird ist sehr sehr wichtig ist echter
meilenstein für die bezahlung von
pflegekräften nach tarif und für die
entlastung von familien und
pflegebedürftigen in stationärer in den
stationären einrichtungen
aber wir hatten auch noch ein paar mehr
ideen und die waren in der
bundesregierung nicht konsensfähig und
ich sage noch einmal wenn es jetzt auch
in anderen ministerien eine bereitschaft
gibt
für dieses thema eine lösung zu finden
die am ende vor allem den familien und
den betreuungs und pflegekräften hilft
beiden muss es ja helfen
das werde idealzustand dann können wir
noch ein konzept erarbeiten das wird an
der nächsten regierung die einer sofort
sozusagen umsetzungs fertig vorlegen
können bis jetzt war der bremser in
dieser frage das zur regel nicht das
bundesministerium für gesundheit sie
kurz die zweite frage beantwortet zu den
techniker sagen will eine frage war
eigentlich hier die vereinbarung wäre
schön wenn wir uns weiter dran halten
eigentlich gerne also wir haben wir im
letzten jahr ein konzept erstellt das
ist seitdem auch öffentlich bekannt und
die die forderung oder die empfehlung
und dieses konzept gelte nach wie vor
also masken tragen und zwar rede ich von
wirklich chirurgische mund nasen schutz
und festungen
inzwischen können wir aber empfehlen wir
eher testungen es gibt solche es gibt
inzwischen auch testmöglichkeiten die
ihm für die kinder nicht so schmerzhaft
sind lollis und spuckt test und sowas
und dann kann man mit pool tests
arbeiten das heißt mit pc also wir
empfehlen einen pcr wo man mehrere
proben pult und dann hat man mit der pca
insgesamt höheren nachweis
empfindlichkeit als mit den anti gen
test bei den anti gen tests erwischen
sie ja nur die menschen die sind sehr
hohe viruslast in den oberen atemwegen
haben mit dem pc sind sie sensitiver und
natürlich lüften natürlich womöglich die
co2 ampel aufstellen
das sind empfehlungen vom
umweltbundesamt dieser zu beachten sind
und somit kann man dann eben schulen
offen halten und infektion früh erkennen
und dadurch dann nur einzelne kinder die
infiziert sind dann eben in eine
quarantäne oder isolierung tun das ist
das ziel ist die schule aufzuhalten aber
eben mit einem sicheren unterricht und
diese diese ganzen rezepte und konzepte
die sind eigentlich da die haben sich
nicht geändert außer dass wir jetzt eine
pool tester für pc empfehlen würden weil
einfach genug pcr kapazität kreis ich
kann es jedenfalls nur begrüßen dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen schulministerin
und minister aus den ländern ja gesagt
haben sie wollen genau das alles für
nach dem sommer vorbereiten damit
ist viel normaler schulbetrieb möglich
ist chirurgische masken ist übrigens zu
werden denn das sonst in europa machen
wir damit jetzt nicht der eindruck
entsteht etwas neues eingeführt das in
die nächste frage der kollege von 16 v
sonntag welt fernsehen eine
anschlussfrage dazu auch zum thema
masken in schulen
der professor will er sie haben sich
geäußert und auch davon gesprochen dass
möglicherweise auch im frühjahr auch die
notwendigkeit gibt oder zumindest die
empfehlung auch masken zu tragen
die frage wäre jetzt im frühjahr sind
wir wahrscheinlich in einer situation in
der die impfkampagne gewissermaßen
dahingehend durch ist dass alle eine
impfung haben die sie auch wollen
vielleicht auch vor erkrankte kinder und
jugendliche dann ändert sich ja an der
situation wenig kann man dann eigentlich
daraus auch folgern dass es nicht nur im
frühjahr diese empfehlung gibt sondern
vielleicht für die nächsten jahre sogar
die empfehlung in schulen auch masken zu
tragen also zunächst einmal beobachten
wir die ganze zeit oder analysieren die
situation dass das ist ja klar das heißt
also wie lange wir am masten empfehlen
sind ja wirklich dann vom vom
infektionsverlauf ab es gibt einen
aspekt in denen wir wissen müssen also
im herbst werden sicher die zahlen
steigen das ist das ist normal und dass
das weiß ja auch inzwischen jeder
saisonalität es wird steigen die frage
ist wie hoch es steigt wir können dafür
zu beitragen dass es nicht so hoch
steigt aber etwas auf das ich auch noch
hinweisen möchte was manche auch
vergessen wird in der situation
wir haben wir mit diesem tragen von
masken haben wir ja wirklich ganz viele
andere atemwegsinfektionen wirklich ganz
niedrig gehalten also das waren wirklich
sehr erfolgreiche maßnahmen und nun gibt
es ja in der regel im winter auch eine
influenza welle also diese grippewelle
und bei grippe da weiß man vorher nie
welche virusvarianten unterwegs sind da
gibt es große viel größere genetische
änderungen im erbgut als dass bewohner
die in der fall ist dann gibt es zeiten
wo kinder mehr betroffen sind mal gibt
es zwei ältere mehr betroffen sind und
das heißt also mit dem masten tragen
über den winter hat man auch da eine
schutzfunktion deshalb ist der aspekt
dass die atemwegserkrankungen steigen
eben im winter und im frühjahr gehen sie
runter das ist der kern der aussage
aber bis zum bis zum frühjahr ist sehen
wir dass momentan sehen wir diese
entwicklung so die nächste frage der
kollege ein paar reihen weiter davor das
bohren sagt ttf an herrn sparen und zwar
auch in folge dessen was wir jetzt
gerade zu den schulen sagt zeit ersparen
wie wollen sie den eltern und schülern
erklären dass einerseits zum ersten juli
die home office pflicht entfällt jetzt
aber schon wieder mit einschränkungen
für die schulen gearbeitet wird sind für
sie kinder und schüler besondere
infektion style was wir sagen wo drauf
hinweisen ist ja dass wir erst einmal
die situation immer wieder neu bewerten
müssen in der jeweiligen auch jahreszeit
aber die jahreszeit hat immer auch
offenkundig dass wir mittlerweile wissen
was mit dem infektionsgeschehen zu tun
und deswegen kann man ja weil der
aktuellen inzidenz bei dem aktuellen
infektionsgeschehen in dieser jahreszeit
dinge anders handhaben als am ersten
dezember oder am ersten januar mit einer
inzidenz von wo wir am ersten januar
waren aber jedenfalls deutlich über 100
im winter und das ist ja auch das was
sie immer sagen wir passen die maßnahmen
und da sind wir ja auch wieder bei den
debatten die abwägung fragen auch am
endeffekt das infektionsgeschehen an
wir können ja nicht die massnahmen die
gegolten haben bei einer inzidenz von
150 oder 200 oder 100 aufrecht erhalten
bei einer landesweiten inzidenz von 6
uhr keinen landkreis mehr über 50 ist
und nur einer über 35 also ja das machen
die länder ja auch werden die maßnahmen
entsprechend angepasst aber nicht auf
null also ist ja nicht so dass ist
irgendwo gar keine schutz
fragen mehr gäbe und das gilt jetzt auch
für den start in den sommer das ist sehr
geil in den die schule aus dem sommer
was ich gerade gesagt habe und die
länder weisen zu recht darauf hin dass
das ihre originäre zuständigkeit ist und
ich nehme einfach war dass eltern und
kinder die berechtigte erwartung haben
dass das nach diesen schulferien besser
konzeptionell klappt als nach der
letzten und je nachdem wie gut es
gelingt das unter kontrolle zu haben ist
dann so viel schulalltag und so viel
normalität ist eben geht möglich und sie
ist eigentlich auch nötig also wir alle
spüren ja wie sehr kinder und
jugendliche das brauchen wie hart die
letzten monate für sie waren wir wollen
so viel normalität wie möglich möglich
machen und gleichzeitig bestmögliche
sicherheit geben und das wird eben
lageangepasst dann entschieden für nach
dem sommer und dann auch in herbst und
winter vielleicht noch eine ergänzung
natürlich ist ein unterschied weil bei
den erwachsenen werden wir einfach
höhere impfraten haben im quoten haben
das heißt die jünger die menschen in
deutschland werden desto größer ist die
chance für diese jüngeren menschen
infiziert zu werden das heißt also auch
der der infektionsdruck wie wir das so
umgangssprachlich sagen auf die jüngeren
wird natürlich darin steigen und gerade
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
natürlich aufmerksam sind und doch nach
wie vor die dann schützen und dass sie
sich selber gut schützen können also das
ist auch eine veränderung gegen gewalt
zum letzten jahr wo wir eben noch keine
impfung notiert hat daran anschließend
nämlich nochmal die frage von jürgen
klöckler handelsblatt er fragt nämlich
den minister und herrn wieder mit dem
stichwort herdenimmunität welchen anteil
der altersgruppe 12 bis 18 müsste dafür
geimpft werden
also zuerst einmal war die meldung sei
der bundesrat im übrigen auch das
aufholen programm für kinder und
jugendliche gerade beschlossen ist ein
aspekt der frage dass eben auch im fokus
zu haben die sorgen nöte probleme die
dort sind und sie auch konkret durch
unterstützung zu adressieren die frage
der impfquote ist ja am ende eine frage
der der mathematik
wenn ich ein einbrechen wichtig auch
noch richtig im kopf habe um 70 prozent
im quote für deutschland zu erreichen
insgesamt über die gesamtbevölkerung
braucht es 80 prozent bei den über
18-jährigen und 50 prozent bei den
zwölf- bis 18-jährigen jetzt nur das
kann man ja mathematisch jeweils her
leisten ist jeweils drei satz dass je
nach umso höher die impfbereitschaft und
impfquote bei den über 18-jährigen ist
mit desto geringere impfquote bei
jüngeren können sie dann eine insgesamt
hohe impfquoten erreichen
aber ich sage noch einmal das ist
wichtig sind individuelle entscheidung
von kindern jugendlichen ihren eltern
und dem impfen den arzt und diese
individuelle entscheidung wären
sicherlich jetzt im lichte der
entwicklungen rund um delta der
erfahrung israel den schulen sicherlich
viele dann für sich auch einfach abwägen
das angebot jedenfalls steht bis ende
august soll jeder und jede über zwölf
der die will das mit den eltern in den
platz entscheidet auch mindestens eine
erste impfung erhalten haben können von
dieser tragödie
dann versuche ich eine letzte frage
heute herr rinke danke knüpft direkt an
herr sander sagten vorhin gesagt dass
wir wegen der delta variante eine höhere
quote brauchen können sie uns dann
zahlen nennen und weist sich das nicht
mit dem trend dass die zweite impfung
moment teilweise wieder abgesagt werden
weil die leute keine notwendigkeit sehen
die termine wahrzunehmen also die zeit
zu benennen ist aktuell noch nicht
möglich dafür muss man die sogenannte
basis reproduktions zahl wissen von von
der delta variante kam bisher nur
abschätzen und da anhand dessen könnte
man einen sogenannten herdenimmunität
schwellenwert berechnen aber das spielen
ganz viele andere dinge mit rein wie zum
beispiel auch die tatsache dass trotz
vollständiger impfung vielleicht bei
bestimmten leuten dennoch eine infektion
stattfinden kann
nichtsdestotrotz ist es relativ klar sie
ist infektiöser und deswegen muss auch
das ist eben dass es eben auch wieder
mathematik auch die impfquote höher sein
um diese effekte zu sehen die wir zu
beginn auch in israel gesehen haben wie
wir jetzt ja auch glücklicherweise in
deutschland sehen
um die effekte zu haben braucht man
möglichst
quote und insbesondere eben auch bei
jungen erwachsenen die viele kontakte
haben dem berufsleben sind die auch zur
verbreitung beitragen
von daher man kann eigentlich nur dabei
bleiben so hoch wie möglich und diesen
appell mal wieder machen und auch diese
initiativen in auch in bereichen der
gesellschaft rein zu gehen wo bislang
die impfquote noch zu niedrig ist da
dieses angebot zu erneuern auch die
informationen bereitzustellen dass die
impfung angenommen wird weil das ist
auch ganz klar wir haben vorab viel über
über einschränkungen diskutiert und die
kann man eben weiter zurückfahren je
mehr leute sich impfen lassen das ist
eine relativ einfache rechnung
ich bin nur 1 zu den zweites ist ja bis
jetzt eher anekdotisch also sagt nach
einzel erfahrungen zusammengeführte
aussage mit dem zweiten warum weil wir
natürlich ist eine sache ich den
kollegen seit wochen in den ländern
natürlich nicht wenige bürger haben die
gleichzeitig beim ins zentrum einen
termin habe möglicherweise bei ihrem
hausarzt gehen oder jetzt beim
betriebsarzt das angebot zur impfung
bekommen dann steht man bei der im
zentrum vielleicht noch auf der
terminliste weil man möglicherweise
vergessen hat abzusagen hat aber die
zweite impfung beim haushalt schon
bekommen
das heißt nicht dass die zweite impfung
die stattgefunden hat das ist halt
wichtig das können wir jetzt noch nicht
also ich sehe nach den zahlen wir haben
jeden tag jetzt über zwei drei wochen
mehr zweikämpfe als erstimpfung weil ab
das war ja absehbar das haben wir immer
gesagt der juni wird auch ein monat mit
vielen sehr vielen zweite impfung werden
wenn sie mal schauen wie stark die zahl
der folge schützen in den letzten drei
wochen gestiegen ist auf jetzt 34 über
34% dann haben wahnsinnig viele
dankenswerterweise eben auch trotz
möglicherweise sonstigen an bestehenden
verpflichtungen zweitimpfung termin
wahrgenommen und ich kann jetzt noch
nicht sehen dass das flächendeckend
nicht der fall wäre
sondern was gerade passiert ist dass die
wartelisten bei impfzentren und
hausärzten sich sozusagen automatisch
abgleichen einfach dadurch dass man dann
feststellt der oder diejenige ist schon
geimpft obwohl bei uns noch auf der
warteliste
und das wird sich jetzt in den nächsten
zwei drei wochen glaube ich besonders
intensiv klären und dann eben auch
zeigen die ersten arztpraxen erlebe ich
das ist jetzt spanische anekdotische
empirie auch aber die jedenfalls
impfdosen über haben am ende der woche
und sagen wir könnten jetzt eigentlich
noch ein paar die wollen impfen wir
haben die ersten impf zentren und länder
die es erleben dass wenn sie impftermine
neue freischalten für erstimpfung nicht
innerhalb von einer stunde oder halben
stunde alles verbucht ist sondern nach
zwei drei tagen immer noch freie termine
da sind ich habe sogar bei social media
gesehen dass in berlin für impfterminen
potsdam geworben wird die man schon
übermorgen haben könnte
also mein eindruck ist dass wir jetzt
langsam in die phase kommen herr
professor sander professor wieder
angesprochen haben diejenigen die
unbedingt wollen werden in den nächsten
wochen alle sehr bald wahrscheinlich
schon ihre impfung haben jetzt geht es
darum diejenigen zu erreichen die
vielleicht überlegen die zögern die
simme aufschieben die niemals termin
nehmen die man in der universität gut
erreichen kann im betrieb im stadtteil
in der moschee neben der kirche auf dem
marktplatz und das wird jetzt stärker
stattfinde und stattfinden muss ich
bitte um verständnis diejenigen deren
fragen heute unbeantwortet bleiben
mussten vor der nächsten veranstaltung
brauchen wir aber noch ein bisschen zeit
um hier nochmal durchzulüften
deswegen beende ich jetzt diese
pressekonferenz danke noch mal herkommen
bis zum nächsten mal